[Musik]
herzlich willkommen heute tauchen wir
ein in die welt von facebook instagram
und youtube in die welt der sozialen
medien in der die allermeisten
jugendlichen aber auch viele erwachsene
täglich mehrere stunden verbringen wo
milliarden von bildern uns überfluten
privates öffentlich gemacht und das
leben der anderen gespitzelt wird was
macht das mit uns und wie wollen wir als
gesellschaft damit umgehen darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit wolfgang im
schnitt er ist filmkritiker und betreibt
einen erfolgreichen youtube kanal sowie
mehrere podcasts und mit anna mélanie
journalistin autorin und aktivistin für
einen bewussteren und gesünderen umgang
mit diesen dingern hier herzlich
willkommen in beiden vielen dank für die
einladung
famila wie wir suchtpotenzials steckten
in dem smartphone für sie persönlich
naja ich glaube ich hätte dieses thema
nicht ausgesucht wenn es nicht auch
darum gegangen wäre einen eigenen weg zu
machen und ich habe sehr viel sich
suchtpotenzial darin gesehen und sehe
dass immer noch und ich glaube genau
darum geht es dass wir in eine digitale
balance kommen oder eben es geht um die
frage wie können wir digitalisierung in
unserem leben haben und uns aber nicht
davon verrückt machen lassen das heißt
sie beraten auch andere wie wir damit
achtsam umgehen und darf mal das ding
weg legen können aber sie beraten heisst
sich selbst auch also sie kämpfen auch
mit dies also absolut und ich glaube es
wäre absolut absurd also ich glaube die
meisten menschen die ein thema für sich
finden finden ein thema aus dem eigenen
leidensdruck heraus und und gibt auch
bekannte psychologen dieser die sagen ja
ich glaube
eine große sehnsucht oder dein größtes
trauma ist auch deine größte begabung
und ich glaube ich also ich interessiere
mich auch sehr für dieses thema weil es
eben nicht ein gerät ist sondern es ist
was ganz großes für mich das thema von
verbundenheit also von von menschlichen
sehnsüchten von der sucht nach
anerkennung von gesehen werden wollen
also da steckt ganz viel menschen ganz
genau psychologische nach den acht es
ist dieser button dieses gleicht dieses
teilen dieses sharing diese
verbundenheit darüber müssen wir
unbedingt noch noch reden wie ist das
bei ihnen herr schmidt wie für such
potential ist da drin ich habe mich wie
odysseus selbst gefesselt um dem
sirenengesang zu entgehen und zwar habe
ich zwar ein smartphone das sich aber
ohne vertrag betreibe sondern ich habe
es einfach nur neben einem laptop liegen
um damit instagram zu machen aber sonst
spielt das smartphone in meinem leben
keine rolle also ihr internetzugang
läuft nicht über smartphone und sie
nutzen sagt nicht zum telefonieren nein
was ich nutze zum telefonieren ein altes
nokia echt jetzt ja ein sehr altes nokia
das erste spiel ist es auch selbstschutz
oder wer das ist ja denn ich glaube man
verbummelt doch sehr schnell sehr viel
zeit und ich weiß darum und natürlich
geht es mir auch so wenn ich am laptop
arbeiten dass man doch mal wieder zehn
minuten 20 minuten per twitter ist und
um das nicht noch weiter auszuweiten
versuche ich dann die smartphone zeit
möglichst gering zu halten indem ich
einfach gar nicht mit dem smartphone
irgendetwas anfangen kann das ist ja
interessant und paradox gleichzeitig
weil sie haben unglaublich viele
follower auf youtube und twitter und auf
instagram also in diesen sozialen medien
sind sie eigentlich gut präsent ja viele
jahre eine große voller schafft viele
anhänger aber selbst verbringen sie da
wenig zeit um zu schauen was andere
machen genau weil ich auch zeit brauche
um ja die inhalte zu produzieren die ich
eigentlich auf den sozialen plattformen
haben möchte wie zum beispiel filme
analysen und dafür muss man nicht nur
viele filme sehen sondern auch viele
bücher lesen und das braucht zeit sie
interessant camilla ist sie haben sie
sind gründerin des digitalen swaps also
dass wir eine balance finden kann man
vielleicht sagen im umgang mit
digitalisierung oder mit diesen geräten
haben wir dann als gesellschaft wenn sie
sagen als großteil der gesellschaft die
balance verloren ja absolut also ich
glaube das ist auch ganz vielen leuten
latent oder sehr bewusst bewusst und
dann finde ich ist die frage sehr
wichtig oder damit befasse ich mich
worum geht's hier eigentlich also ein
bisschen kitschig gesagt was suche ich
in diesem internet
und aus emotionaler oder psychologische
oder auch soziologischer sicht ist es
einfach ein bisschen komplizierter also
ich glaube man dieses titel die talks
das kann man mal machen aber ich glaube
das ist einfach zu kurz gegriffen weil
das ist wie wenn du nicht jede macht es
geht um dann erst du dich nicht
automatisch gesund und es geht auch
nicht darum dass wir jetzt nie wieder
netz fließen dürfen oder nie wieder
irgendwie eine halbe stunde auf social
media und scrollen wenn wir einen
schlechten tag hatten es geht aber um
bewusstheit also um einen nachhaltigen
umgang um einen um einen entschiedenen
umgang und ich finde was herr schmidt
gerade gesagt hat davon kann man halten
was man will aber ich finde das absolut
wichtigste daran ist hat sich aktiv
entschieden hat sich gedanken darüber
gemacht was will ich mit diesem gerät
wie teile ich meine zeit auf und was ist
im kern für das was ich der welt geben
möchte und mir selber genug wichtig oder
worum geht es im kern und wie schütze
ich diesen kern also dass er sagt ich
möchte inhalte produzieren und daneben
das ist total wichtig bei diesem thema
sich die frage zu stellen eben das was
was was möchte ich geben was möchte ich
worum geht es mir im kern aber man kann
auch sagen sachen schöner zeitvertreib
auf social media ein bisschen videos zu
gucken das sind absolut so dass selbst
den spieltrieb sind warum ist das so
gefährlich wie gefährlich ist es über
ich glaube der punkt es eben dieses
sowohl-als-auch also es ist lustig und
wir möchten spaß und wir möchten
ablenkungen also das menschliche gehirn
ist nicht dazu gemacht sich 24 stunden
am tag zu konzentrieren also und und und
wir menschen das ist auch ein wichtiger
aspekt wir überschätzen
systematisch unsere willenskraft also es
geht auch nicht darum das internet
abzuschaffen und das abzustellen aber es
geht darum irgendwann und das ist der
springende punkt ganz viele menschen
gerade im heutigen zeitalter sehnen sich
ganz tief nach lebendigkeit und alle
reden immer von großen glocken aber die
wollen was spüren wir wollen das spüren
wir wollen in kontakt sein mit uns mit
der umwelt mit mitmenschen wir haben
eine große sehnsucht nach verbundenheit
und verbundenheit wir haben solche wir
haben das ist so ein urbedürfnis dass
wir vor ein paar jahren angefangen haben
als ganze gesellschaften dieser
verbundenheit oder eben verbindung
connection im internet zu suchen und wir
haben so viel agi darauf investiert das
herzustellen dass wir an einen punkt
gekommen sind wo wir in meinen augen und
glaube ich nicht mal meinen augen diese
verbundenheit zu uns selbst und zur
realen welt halten stück war ein
wirklich verloren haben zugleich kann es
aber auch eine möglichkeit sein um
überhaupt mit menschen in kontakt zu
kommen ich würde auch sagen wir brauchen
direkte begegnungen und deswegen treffen
wir uns ja auch heute hier und sagen
nicht einfach wir machen das über summen
das ist schon etwas anderes wenn man
hier sitzt aber das internet ermöglicht
auch dass man leute kennenlernt die man
sonst nicht getroffen hätte gerade wenn
man nicht vielleicht in einer besonderen
großstadt lebt nur ist dann wichtig dass
man irgendwann diesen schritt aus dem
internet wieder heraus geht um sich dann
in der realität zu treffen und es ist
ganz wichtig was von mir gesagt man kann
nicht einfach das internet abstellen und
ich mache das ja auch jetzt nur ganz
partiell auf das smartphone bezogen
sonst bin ich ja mit dem laptop auch
ständig irgendwie vernetzt und setzt
damit auch in der bahn wenn das internet
funktioniert aber es muss schon auch
darum gehen dass man erkennt wenn der
durchschnittliche smartphone user 4,8
stunden am tag mit diesem ding zu bringt
und man weiß tik tok er hat mir
durchschnittlicher smartphone hero 5
stunden ja ja und das steigt immer
weiter und die tik tok nutzung steigt
immer weiter wir sind ja auch schon fast
bei einer stunde angekommen bei den
jüngeren schon weit über einer stunde
dann macht das natürlich etwas mit uns
was macht das mit uns kann kann sich zum
beispiel nicht mehr so gut konzentrieren
auf andere themen man kann sich nicht
dann so einfach nach einer stunde tik
tok abmelden und sagen ich lese jetzt
drei stunden ein philosophisches buch
das wird schwierig werden denn das
beeinflusst natürlich auch das denken
auch diese unglaubliche kurzatmigkeit
die zerrüttet uns und die fragmentierte
auch die streitkultur und all das was
uns eigentlich wichtig sein sollte und
der körper kommt zu kurz das ist ja auch
diese direktheit sie haben so eine
verbundenheit gesprochen das ist ja auch
sehr und körperlich was wir als der
körper stets war im zentrum da die sehen
viele körper aber unsere eigenen körper
ist unwichtig und und gerade auf die
körperlichkeit bezogen und das ist ein
wichtiger punkt eben auf die frage was
macht das mit und könnten wahrscheinlich
18 stunden alle themen also das ist
riesig aber
wir haben ein gehirn und wir haben ein
nervensystem und das ist seit
jahrtausenden das gleiche das hat sich
minimal biologisch verändert und das ist
ganz zentral zu viel um zu verstehen
dass wir haben ein paar sympathisch ist
und sympathisches nervensystem also wir
haben eine aktivierung des körpers oder
des systems und eine deaktivierung
beziehungsweise eine beruhigung also
wenn wir schlafen gehen ist der körper
in einer beruhigung wenn wir uns aktiv
bewegen ist er in einer
angespannteren oder aktiveren situation
das smartphone und wenn man neurobiologe
schaut es das macht wenn tausende
eindrücke videos pendenzen dinge
endlose tut digitale to-do-listen hass
und wenn du wenn du 24 stunden 7 mit
einem gerät um läufst du dich die ganze
zeit nur 500 mal gegen sie am tag pusht
dann stresst dich das auf einer
körperlichen ebene unter punkt ist und
gewünscht ein system daran dass es in
constanta lot ist als in einer
konstanten alarmbereitschaft und das
heißt und das ist sehr wichtig zu
verstehen der körper reagiert der körper
reagiert mit stresssymptomen von
schmerzen schlafstörungen und du hast
einen höheren angst und stress level das
heißt dass du auf der neurologischen
ebene deine umwelt weniger wahrnimmst
sie gefährlicher wahrnimmst und
tatsächlich neurobiologisch weniger in
der lage bist überhaupt in einem
verbundenheit reinzukommen und das ist
das ist unter und da eben da geht es
darum balance das heißt bei uns das
heißt zum beispiel dass man anfängt sich
bewusst zu machen okay ich fühle ich
mich gerade in meinem körper was habe
ich gerade in mich hineingefressen was
habe ich schon alles gesehen heute und
möchte ich nach einem langen arbeitstag
in der vollen u-bahn irgendwie noch
musik hören und podcast und noch ein
video und obendrauf oder ist mahlzeit
ein bisschen runter zu fahren und dem
system überhaupt mal ruhe zu im jahres
das wird er gemacht also es gibt diese
kompensation im analogen also es gibt
yoga kurs ist achtsamkeit mein volles
haus im trend körperbewusstsein so
meditation sehr präsent im internet im
übrigen
aber sie würden wahrscheinlich sagen
dass bedingt sich gegenseitig ja es ist
aufgefallen dass sehr viele influenza
die davon leben dass leute sehr abhängig
sind von den sozialen medien nun dazu
übergehen und auch werbung zu machen für
irgendwelche digital die talks programme
und natürlich ist das immer so ein
bisschen eigenartig wenn die die das
problem verursacht haben jetzt auch noch
die lösung präsentieren da kann man
sagen so intelligent ist der
kapitalismus nun mal aber es stimmt ein
schon ein bisschen melancholisch wenn
auch die leute die das problem schaffen
plötzlich da sind als die retter die man
jetzt in empfang nehmen soll und ich
glaube da sollte man eher mal darüber
nachdenken ob es nicht wirklich radikale
gegenwelten gibt zu dem was die ganze
zeit im netz omnipräsent ist und ich
glaube auch dass man stundenlang im netz
verbringen kann auf sehr sinnvolle weise
als man kann ja sehr lange texte sich
durchlesen oder man kann ja podcast
konsumieren dann hat man auch stimmen
zwei morden ist man auch in einer
anderen präsenz als jetzt hier in einer
unmittelbaren aber doch ist das eine
ganz andere möglichkeit als ein medium
wie tik tok oder instagram das einen
dazu verführt permanent in so eine
pseudo interaktivität zu treten das
heißt man neigt man tut man kommentiert
man klickt weiter und man hat den
eindruck man hat die ganze zeit etwas
gemacht aber eigentlich ist da eine
große leere und ein großes rauschen sie
interessant also das ist ja auch dieses
multitasking dieses kurz kurz futter
dann am abend schaut man zurück ersten
tagen fragt sich was habe ich heute
gemacht und da ist diese diese lehre wir
möchten jetzt im folgenden ein bisschen
einsteigen in diese welt der social
media und da gibt es ja viele auch um
selbstinszenierung also man fotografiert
sich selbst stellt sich aus wie man lebt
und so weiter ein großes sehen und
gesehen werden könnte man sagen so
müssen exhibitionismus man stellt sich
auch selbst ins leere aber auch
voyeurismus man schaut sie wissen was
die großen stars und sternchen zu machen
was macht das mit uns vielleicht mal
dieses juristische also ich kann jetzt
da hingehen und cristiano ronaldo folgen
oder kylie jenner oder sonstigen stars
und in pflanzen und den zuschauen wie
sie vermeintlich authentisch erleben da
leben was was passiert damit wir
versuchen uns natürlich bei diesem
social media konsum sehr stadt zu
identifizieren mit den influenza und man
darf nicht vergessen es gibt zum einen
die stars die in den sozialen medien
sind die übergroßen filmstars oder
fußballstars und dann gibt es aber auch
leute die zu social media stars geworden
sind aus dem kinderzimmer heraus und die
suggerieren eine besondere nähe die
sagen nämlich eigentlich ich bin wieder
nachbar ich bin wieder ein bruder ich
bin wie deine beste freundin und dadurch
entsteht auch eine große abhängigkeit
denn die follower glauben tatsächlich in
einer kommunikation auf augenhöhe sich
zu befinden mit diesen social media
stars die aber in wahrheit natürlich
auch entfernt entrückt sind wenn sie
mehrere millionen follower haben bei den
echten filmstars da ist es doch klar
dass es da eine kluft gibt wir glauben
nicht wirklich brett zu sein wenn wir im
kino sitzen auch wenn wir danach
vielleicht ganz kurz die sehnsucht haben
aber wenn wir dort leute sehen die die
ganze zeit sagen ich hab's geschafft du
kannst es auch schaffen dann setzt das
die follower auch unter enormen druck
zum beispiel was muss sich leisten wie
muss ich aussehen war ich heute schon
beim sport und wenn nein warum noch
nicht würden sie sagen dass sie seien
der großen botschaften der trend ich
habe es geschafft du kannst es auch
schaffen was diese aufstiegsversprechen
das aufstiegsversprechen ist ganz
vehement da und das wird gerade da
besonders laut wo der eigentliche
aufstieg durch bildung durch leistung
immer schwieriger wird was ihr american
dream eigentlich vom tellerwäscher zum
großen star den donald trump zu recht
für tot erklärt hat und auch der
soziologe oliver nachtwey spricht er von
der abstiegs gesellschaft und wir
erleben aber da dass es tatsächlich
einige wenige geschafft haben und jetzt
ist es problem nur dass die iren
verloren nahelegen jeder kann es
schaffen wenn er sich nur recht bemüht
und das ist eine große lüge da bin ich
alles da sein können ja aber wir
inszenieren uns dann selbst auch so
müssen als das zeigen uns von der besten
seite also wenn ich etwas schönes ersten
fotografieren wir das wenn wir irgendwie
keine ahnung was großes geleistet haben
eine reise machen dann posten wäre das
also wir gehen in diese spirale mit ein
ja obwohl jetzt gerade bei diesem ich
poste man essen ich glaube also das ist
ja auch eine interessante saison babbel
phänomen also beim erstes total vorbei
also ich glaube jeder der sich aber das
ist ja auch wieder der identitäts
geschichte jeder der sich irgendwie
links alternativ intellektuell also sind
dann ganz andere themen das ist ein
feminismus ist und das haben sie ja auch
angetönt ihrem buch das ist dann der
klimawandel also das hat dass das sind
ja
das sind einfach verschiedene
[Musik]
vielleicht auch sozioökonomische
realitäten und
ja und ich glaube eben also ich glaube
so 111 ii wenn ich jetzt sehr viel mache
und dann sieht man noch mal einen halben
arm das ist das ist nicht mehr am bug
also weil das ist er das hat sich ja vom
vom das hat sich von der definition das
hat sich in der bildsprache ganz stark
geändert das war dann eher so das thema
auto bis allein unterwegs
sehr
interessant also die selbstinszenierung
ist wie schon vorbei werden sie sagen
was authentisch ist da oder
inwiefern wir in ein zeitalter der
inszenierten authentizität kommen das
müssen wir besprechen aber ich glaube
schon dass und ich hoffe auch dass das
die sozialen medien sich wandeln oder
das vielmehr politische
diskussionen oder zumindest der ansatz
an der politischen diskussion irgendwie
möglich werden oder sein werden und ich
glaube auch ehrlicherweise des
social media oder dass die sozialen
medien nicht weggehen und dass wir uns
genau deswegen weil sie nicht weggehen
die frage stellen müssen was wollen wir
auf diesen plattformen sehen wir sollten
diesen plattformen funktionieren wir
wollen wir auf diesen plattformen
unterwegs sein und das ist sowohl eine
individuelle geschichte als auch eine
politische als auch eine
gesellschaftliche nur sprechen wir nicht
von einer nische die vielleicht nicht
dass alfie macht die nicht das essen
fotografiert nicht das neue auto
vorführt aber wenn man sich mal an und
zwar global welche influenza sind am
erfolgreichsten dann sind es influenza
die ihren body zeigen die ihren luxus
zeigen die sich auf reisen zeigen die
status updates geben von ihrem tollen
leben und das ist das was die meisten
leute sehen er schmeckt wahrscheinlich
uns jetzt machen sie haben nämlich ein
wundervolles buch geschrieben zusammen
mit ole neuen influenza die ideologie
der werbe körper und was soll die
influenza machen schauen wir uns mal an
einem wahrscheinlich paradebeispiel an
das ist kylie jenner
man kennt sie aus der reality-show
keeping up with the kardashians
noch ein eigenes kosmetik label wir mal
[Musik]
ehrlich warum ist keine typische
influenza nun zwecks ist die familie
etwas ungewöhnlich sie ist ja über das
reality fernsehen da hineingeschlittert
aber es war so dass die kardashians
recht früh verstanden haben dass sie mit
dem smartphone ganz marxistisch
gesprochen die produktionsmittel in der
hand haben sie brauchen nicht mehr ein
kamerateam sondern sie können sich
selbst filme und können alles dort
hochladen im internet und die mutter der
kardashians hatte auch mal gesagt dass
es da erst irritationen gab die obwohl
er fand das gar nicht so toll dass man
sich da plötzlich selbst filmen soll und
darstellt aber sie haben es dann
geschafft zur social media stars zu
werden und nicht nur produkt
kooperationen zu machen werbekooperation
sondern auch eigene linien herauszugeben
eigene hypes zu produzieren wann der
neue sneaker herauskommt oder das
neueste make up und dann hat man 48
stunden zeit es zu kaufen und man muss
sich vielleicht sogar verschulden über
clara um es kaufen zu können also diese
ganzen hype see oder beobachten das
haben die kardashians ganz früh
verstanden und deswegen sind sie solche
leitfiguren für das influenza market
aber das ist ganz wichtig dieses
marketing diese werbung also man
verkauft irgendwas probierte und jemand
wie barack obama oder so hat auch viele
vorlage aber das ist kein interesse aus
ihrer sicht weiterverkauf sozusagen
nichts materielles ja ich würde diese
unterscheidung auf jeden fall machen
wollen denn sonst wird das alles zu weit
wenn wir einfach sagen alle die im
internet sind und eine gewisse
reichweite haben sind influenza weil sie
einfluss haben dann können wir auch
sagen alle die schon mal was getwittert
haben sind philosophen oder so das
bringt uns nichts wir müssen erkennen
dass in pflanzen ist ganz eng an das
marketing gekoppelt und es ist nicht bei
diesen inflation so dass sie eigentlich
andere inhalte anbieten und
zwischendurch werbung sondern der
primäre inhalt bei diesen in fenstern
ist die werbung was wiederum heißt die
verlor schauen nicht die influenza
obwohl sondern weil es dort werbung
eigentlich dauerwerbesendung ja haben
sie in ihrem buch die wir gerne sehen
das ist der trick der kritik dieses
influenza marke wo man auch verstehen
uns woher es gekommen ist das sind leute
bei den kardashians drückt das jetzt
nicht so bald die meisten influenza
kommen ja aus dem nichts und diese
influenza haben einfach mal angefangen
sich mit der webcam selbst zu filmen
haben das bei youtube da begann es ja
hochgeladen und haben erzählt was sie
den tag über gemacht haben und was tut
man im spätkapitalismus man kauft
natürlich ein und sie zeigten produkte
bis irgendwann die unternehmen bereit
waren produkte zu verschenken damit die
ausgepackt werden von der kamera bis die
influenza- die sich aber ist doch nicht
so genannten verstanden haben wir
könnten eigentlich auch geld dafür
nehmen dass wir diese produkte vor der
kamera zeigen und so ist das in friends
marketing evolutionär entstanden einmal
durch den technischen fortschritt und
durch diese veränderung der
marketingbudgets und sie sagen das ist
sozusagen ganz das lehrt uns ganz
wichtiges über den kapitalismus und
wieder heute funktioniert mein mann kann
sehr zielgenau werbung machen weil man
weiß diejenigen menschen die diese
person folgen die die interessant finden
der können wir die produkte jacke von
sonst hat man einfach diese streuen
werbung ganz richtig und diese
streuwirkung die wird natürlich auch
irgendwann wieder präsent wenn die
vorherrschaft zu groß wird dann ist es
unübersichtlich aber gerade auch im
mikro influencer bereich also bei leuten
die 20 30 tausend follower haben kann
man ganz gezielt werben und man hat auch
direkt die möglichkeiten zu gucken wie
effektiv es diese werbung durch die
rabattcodes durchfährt links all das
sind gefühle die möglichkeit das sind
links auf die man kriegt wo man dann die
produkte bestellen kann und der in
fenster bekommt eine provision aber das
unternehmen bekommt zugleich auch mit
wie erfolgreich diese influenza werbung
machen wieviel gedankliche gewählt haben
deswegen habe dieses geschäft war hatte
dieses video das macht es sehr
transparent ja interessant jetzt schauen
wir für sie familie zweites beispiel an
sich interessant also gespannt bin wie
sie das psychologisch deuten ganz andere
arten von videos die gut laufen zum
beispiel solche challenges also wenn
leute etwa mehrere gläser nutella
innenbahn
und sich daran setzten wir uns warten
wie das aussieht
[Musik]
ja
ja familie man kann fast nicht
wegschauen es ist so gut sieht einen
bann warum hat das so eine große
attraktivität
sind ein paar dinge durch den kopf
gegangen aber ich glaube also ein
begriff oder etwas das mir kam als ich
das gesehen habe ist eben ich glaube und
das genau der punkt diese leute so blöd
es klingt die erleben gerade was und die
überschreiten eine grenze die wir und
das ist ganz wichtig vor dem pc sitzend
gerade nicht überschreiten und ich
glaube das ist einer der fundamentalen
probleme von dieser ganzen geschichte
und von wegen eben was sie dann auch
vorhin gesagt haben guckt das video und
dann geh ins leben und was die meisten
menschen aber machen sie über über
übergeben diesen exzess oder oder diese
diese diese grenzüberschreitung kann ja
auch im positiven sinne sein also in
allem einig grenze endlich fiel genau
das was ich vorhin angesprochen hatte
genau also wir wollen ja des lebens
spüren ja und deswegen haben dann solche
überschreitungen also bald es das da ich
ja alles drin da ist drin dass
vielleicht die eltern den klein machen
da ist drin da ist auch eine gewisse
verschwendung drin da ist eine gewisse
unmoralische handlungen dabei also dass
in ganz china dieses zog los ja genau
genau genau und es ist und das wiederum
dass auch total wichtig ja und und um um
dann bogen zu schlagen ja in florenz
atom und calyon sie haben gesagt
spätkapitalismus ja wir leben in einer
welt in der unglaublicher druck auf uns
alle ausgeübt wird unglaublicher druck
und wir haben endlose pendenzen listen
und immer etwas zu tun immer etwas zu
liken und 7000 verschiedene mails und
keine ahnung was und er musste noch eine
gute mutter sein dann musst du noch
polyamorie und er muss mir noch gedanken
machen wie deine haare aussehen aber zu
den nicht zumindest nicht zu fast glaubt
und dann zweimal im jahr irgendwie in
den urlaub aber dann bitte nicht fliegen
also wir haben bei jedem einzelnen
wasserglas ist gar nicht mehr neutral
und dann hast du mal fünf minuten
dann denkst du geil einfach mal rockig
mal was total sinnentleertes an einfach
diese fünf minuten und das ist
psychologisch glaube ich für viele leute
die einzige rebellion das ist ne das ist
das system sagt du ne
also jetzt nicht auch noch die
waschmaschine ausräumen nicht auch noch
einen klugen gedanken fassen jetzt nicht
bitte nicht auch noch ein
selbsthilfebuch lesen abends um zehn und
dann hocken sie da und kohlen halbe
stunde weil das sozusagen auch in diesem
ganzen unternehmen wäre vielleicht der
ehemann noch was und die kinder und dann
ist es diese mieten diese mieten von
dieser zeit auch wenn sie sinnlos ist
gehört nur mir und ich habe dieses gerät
vor mir das mich abgrenzt und das dem
anderen auch visuell kommuniziert bis
hierher und nicht weiter das ist jetzt
mein raum also und und ich glaube dass
ich finde es wichtig dass wir uns genau
bei solchen dingen das ist nicht einfach
ein internet-phänomen also ich finde das
internet spiegelt all das was hier in
der realen welt haben wo wir nicht
aussah also wo wir nichts dagegen sagen
wo wir nichts dagegen tun also ich finde
bei solchen videos dürfen wir uns auch
die frage stellen ob was läuft in
unserer gesellschaft gerade nicht so
rund
also nicht um das zu werten sondern es
geht
ja genau es geht uns alle was er aber
interessant ist ja wenn es also ich kann
mir vorstellen jemand sieht das bei
diesen challenges ist es ja so man macht
das sonst vielleicht selbst nach aber
einfach nicht nur für sich stehen wird
mit time sondern mal 40 natürlich dafür
also man macht das ganze leben kuratiert
man dann auch für die anderen die
potenziellen verfolger und diejenigen
die zukunft was algorithmischer belohnt
wird gerade bei ticket kann man das
besonders sehen das ist ja extrem
algorithmus getrieben schon deshalb weil
man eigentlich auf dieser for you seite
vom algorithmus nur vorgeschlagenes
angezeigt bekommt man kuratiert gar
nicht mehr selbst das übernimmt der
algorithmus und der belohnt die
wiederkehr des immer gleichen und wenn
irgendein viraler trend in gang gesetzt
wo dann wird das perpetuiert durch den
algorithmus und das wird dann nachgeahmt
von den verloren die dann auch zu
tickern werden können und diese
plattform verspricht dann auch ganz
schnelle aufsteiger aber auch sehr
schnelle abschläge wieder und wir haben
diese viral gehenden trends seit einigen
jahren und sie sind so dominant
inzwischen dass wir uns gar nicht mehr
erinnern können an den trend von
vorletzter woche haben noch so etwas wie
den gang dem style oder so im kopf aber
danach sind die trends so inflationär
geworden dass wir parallel jetzt gerade
wahrscheinlich 100 oder 200 große tip
top trends am von denen wir drei gar
nichts wissen aber das ist echt zum
phänomen als meine tochter hat zum
beispiel diese diese dinger diese
spielzeuge tun und so rein drücken kann
das
motto das heißt diese dinge dass plastik
und der die gibt es ja überall zu kaufen
man fragt sich wer steht das hier wofür
aber ich glaube es geht wirklich um den
trend aus solchen als bayerische rat
gibt es zum beispiel die idee wir wollen
etwas nicht weil wir es morgens und
weist die anderen wollen dass ich habe
ist alles ja natürlich und und das ist
ja dieser also wir haben ja
spiegelneuronen also wenn sie in einem
raum stehen und 15 leute sind bei einer
party und einer fängt an das handy oder
das smartphone vorzunehmen und rum zu
drücken innerhalb der nächsten fünf
minuten garantiere ich ihnen mindestens
50 prozent machen genau das gleiche
unbewusst und es ist aber eben wieder
dieses thema der verbundenheit wir
wollen wir wollen also früher vor ein
paar tausend jahren oder vielleicht auch
schon vor 50 jahren oder auch jetzt noch
ist der ausschluss einer gruppe des also
das war früher der sichere tod und
dessen 60 neurobiologische nicht ob es
das heck hin hat sich nicht geändert
also ob ich jetzt mit fehlenden likes
bestraft werde oder ob dann irgendwie
physisch acht wochen niemand mehr zu mir
nach hause kommt und guckt ob um ihre
suppe kocht das ist genau das gleiche
für das hirn ist es genau das gleiche
was ja und ich finde es findet deswegen
wichtig ja diese also diese
nachahmungseffekt ich glaube diese trend
geschichte die hatten wir ja auch schon
immer aber das thema dort das ich sehe
es sicherheit also wenn es der andere
tut habe ich die erlaubnis ist auch zu
tun und es hat einen riss hat einen
rahmen und unter der mensch pendelt
immer in allem zwischen sicherheit und
autonomie in beziehungen in dem was er
tut der braucht sicherheit und der
braucht frei und ich glaube diese
wiederholung des immer gleichen gibt
sicherheit und aber und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt
wir brauchen psychologisch gesehen
herausforderungen und schwierigkeit um
glücklich zu sein blöd weil wir können
20 stunden gucken und es ist eine
passive das interesse liegt uns in einer
pseudo sicherheit und am ende das haben
sie auch in ihrem buch geschrieben sehen
dann alle tage gleich aus und wir fühlen
aber nichts mehr weil die halt über
unsere eigenen grenzen nicht rausgehen
und wenn du dann sechs stunden mal im
regen mal wieder wandern warst was ja
gar nicht mehr so oft vorkommt genau
gegen diesen prozessen dann spürst du
dich war gar nicht so eine tolle
positive sonnige erfahrung aber die
meisten leute fühlen sich danach
lebendig weil sie sich etwas ausgesetzt
haben das interessant was er wirklich
auch diese idee von ersatzbefriedigung
diese verbundenheit wollen wir aber wir
holen sie auf eine andere weise diese
sicherheit wollen wir dieses dieses
diese geborgenheit vielleicht auch mit
den ritualen
jetzt es gibt ja nicht aus sind karl
jenner und und schokolade sondern es
gibt ja auch viele menschen für die
diese soziale medien große im parlament
bedeuten und eine reichweite für
wichtige anliegen gegen sexismus gegen
rassismus gegen diskriminierung für für
bestimmte werte ich mache mal zwei
beispiele in der schweiz gibt es an
rosenwasser eine queer feministische
aktivist imitieren hier ein bild mein
körper meine meine entscheidung sie
transportiert natürlich auch ideale und
werte und ihre form von aktivismus sieht
man da und erreichen eine große
vorherrschaft oder etwa in deutschland
der inklusions aktivist des raul
krauthausen erzählt klaus knochen und
spricht dann über barrierefreiheit und
einfach sehr verspielte witzige art wir
scheinen uns mal ein kurzes video in
meiner straßberger nach mensch mit
behinderung ich sag ja immer menschen
mit besonderen bedürfnissen
haben keine besonderen bedürfnisse
haben wir doch alle ja klar aber aber
sie sind eben besonders jetzt zeigt so
so speziell ja aber das ist eine
klassische verschönerung ein euphemismus
also ich meine da wird etwas
schöngeredet aber nicht wirklich schöner
gemacht aber wo liegt denn da das
problem wenn man etwas schöner redet das
problem ist dass du die bezeichnung der
betroffenen einfach übergeht und
ignoriert und das ist ignorant
zufrieden der von mir sehr
gut gemacht und auch wichtige inhalte
erreichen sagen großem publikum also man
die these wäre man kann nicht alles
ändern sie haben und ob schmeißt ganz
sicher und wir haben das buch nicht
geschrieben weil wir gegen die sozialen
medien sind sondern gegen eine bestimmte
formen die dort stattfindet und gegen
gewisse soziale figuren nämlich die in
friends at da auftauchen aber dass das
aktivistisch sinnvoll genutzt werden
kann es steht außer zweifel ich würde
sogar sagen
saisontor sagt der franzose also die
alle die nicht da sind haben unrecht ja
man muss wenn man heute aktivist ist auf
diesen plattformen irgendeiner weise
vertreten sein die frage ist nur ob man
primär seine inhalte in den vordergrund
stellen möchte oder ob man irgendwann
die inhalte den hintergrund treten lässt
und wird dann selbst zum influenza und
das ist sehr häufig zu erleben oder
influenza die sich so ein bisschen
aktivismus drauf schaffen weil man da
auch noch eine marktlücke entdeckt weil
sich moral heute gut verkauft aber das
ist ja interessant also ich glaube es
gibt wirklich schon dieses phänomen dem
medium is the message von von marshall
mcluhan also dass das dass das medium
selbst auch die inhalte zuschneidet und
bestimmte art von inhalten präferiert
also zb junge nackte haut dass das
schreiben sie auch wird von den
algorithmen einfach belohnt genau einmal
dass sie das heißt man kann 7 24
stündige podcasts einfach nur hören kann
funktioniert trotzdem aber es ist ein
gegenwert eigentlich im kleinen
funktioniert nicht bei instagram
natürlich funktioniert dann im podcast
markt und da ist sehr viel mehr möglich
auch weil ich alles am körper
festgehalten wird das ist das problem
auch dass wir es beim in friends atom
und auch gerade bei instagram immer mit
der verbindung zum körper zu tun haben
auch wo der körper eigentlich gar keine
rolle spiele muss wo eigentlich mal
inhalt im vordergrund stehen nun haben
wir auch körpern sitzende demir aber wir
müssen nicht unsere inhalte am körper
barbusig oder sonstwie präsentieren das
ist aber in den sozialen medien so lange
es nicht pornographisch wird geradezu
erwünscht und das bringt auch immer mehr
likes man kann sich das auch ansehen
also wo nicht der körper mit auf dem
foto ist gibt es in der regel weniger
likes und ich würde sagen ja marsh
mclennan hat immer noch recht es ist so
dass gewisse medien auch nur gewisse
inhalte zu lassen und bei tecdoc hat das
jetzt hier so als plante funktioniert
aber eine längere auseinandersetzung
über zum beispiel die thematik wie geht
unsere gesellschaft mit menschen mit
behinderungen oder ein wirtschaftliches
thema ist auf tik tok nicht vermittelbar
dazu braucht man das längere youtube
video oder braucht den podcast und warum
steht dieser körper so sehr im
zentimeter am anfang war weil wir
sozusagen ihnen gerne spüren würden aber
in nicht mehr stören aber wir lagen das
so zu sagen wir schauen und den
ermittlungen also ich möchte noch kurz
an fügen also diese idee von die junge
nackte haut also das hat ja nichts mit
social media zu tun also seit seit
menschengedenken ist es so also ich
finde dass frau auf die welt gekommen
und sie also ich habe mich mit 15
irgendwie in kurzen röcken das war noch
vor social media also man weiß ja um
seinen marktwert und ich kann doch seine
intellektuelle frau soll mit zwei master
abschlüssen die jetzt hier sitzt ich
weiß doch dass ich dabei gut aussehen
muss also das ist ja gar nicht kann mich
entscheiden ist nicht zu tun aber die
zuschauenden werden wahrscheinlich
dankbar dafür sein dass ich meine haare
gefönt habe also darüber müssen wir
reden ja und das ist auch wirklich
quantitativen unterschied auch noch mal
wenn man die ganze zeit perfekte körper
mit dem smartphone konsumieren kann
absage ja ganz anderen weise als man das
im fernsehzeitalter machen konnte ja das
ist also die ganze pornografische idee
ist einfach
demokratischer oder sichtbarer geworden
also ich glaube die die erniedrigung
also das hat auch sehr viel mit eben das
schreiben sie ja auch das hat mit
erniedrigung und reproduzieren also dass
er hat mit dem reproduzieren von der
idee zu tun dass frauen einfach körper
sind aber ist das nur bei frauen zb den
eindruck aus dem himalaya länder heute
ja dann machen wir halt noch die
schönheitsoperation dazu dass die männer
jetzt auch entdecken dass also das hat
ja aber das ist ja in der männliche
körper ist absolut nicht gleichwertig
entwertet wieder wie der weibliche
körper aber wir müssen es auch keine
feministische diskussion für neben dafür
gibt es an der rosenwasser oder andere
leute die sich darauf zumindest im
öffentlichen raum aber 77 sorgen dass
sie richtig verstehe das nicht sozusagen
der kanal wo die plattform primär schuld
ist sondern das sind einfach wie also
der sexismus und das sozusagen der
männliche blick auf den auf den
weiblichen körper deutsche vorträgen
also es ist und das ist das ist ein sich
verstärkender das ist sich verstärkend
also und und und und je mehr leute
schlank sind desto eher haben leute ein
problem mit dem die nicht lang sind und
je mehr und akte bilder wir sehen umso
eher haben wir also natürlich bedingt
sich das gegenseitig aber
so viele leute laufen rum und denken
digitalisierung das sind selbst fahrende
autos das ist 5g das ist instagram
die denken dass alles geht nur darum
irgend was
also es geht nicht darum die
zentralbibliothek die die bestände der
zentralbibliothek zu digitalisieren
damit hätte glaube ich niemandem
probleme sondern also alles das was also
algorithmen und das denken leute auch da
macht im silicon valley das stimmt schon
aber erstens waren dass sehr viele junge
männer in die sehr viel zeit in garagen
zone ohne licht verbracht haben also das
sind
und zweitens
also digitalisierung und algorithmen
sind nicht neutral die werden die werden
so konstruiert wie das weltbild im
moment konstruiert ist und deswegen ist
es so wichtig sich proaktiv damit
anfangen anzufangen sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen und auch
aktivistisch und zu sagen okay welches
internet will ich denn also welche
regeln sollen den welten und auf social
media betonen natürlich kann ich jetzt
nicht als privatperson kommen sagen ja
eben ich ändere jetzt die algorithmen
wir natürlich diesen ich ja aber ich
glaube ich glaube dass die gesellschaft
je mehr leute sich bewusst darüber
werden dass sie schon auch entscheidung
macht haben und keine masse die wird die
wird schon was ändern also wir können
natürlich die normen auch umdefinieren
stichwort körper schlankheit oder mosel
oder was auch immer es gibt da auch die
gegenbewegung ja die positive die also
dass jeder körper okay ist somit auch
wieder alles am körper festgemacht wird
also dass es dieses ständige präsenz des
körpers führt eigentlich nicht auf da
weiß ich die katze selbst in den schwanz
man müsste eigentlich darüber nachdenken
und der podcast ist ein gewisser weise
eine antwort wie eine welt aussehen
könnte in der nicht die ganze zeit das
bebildern von körpern und bewerten von
körpern im mittelpunkt steht aber die
influenza verdienen natürlich mit ihrem
körper das geld an ihrem körper testen
sie die produkte und irgendwann liefern
sie dann auch noch innenschau das ist
natürlich auch wichtig dass man zeigt
dieser körper besitzt auch noch eine
seele das ist etwas was auch in der
korona pandemie noch einmal zugenommen
hat diese innenschau das influenza
anfangen zu meinen aber es ist gleich so
eine konsumierbare traurigkeit wieder
die da angeboten wird es ist nicht
wirklich eine irritation es ist nicht
ein neben sich stehen oder auch dem
prozess der veränderung zu lassen es ist
ganz interessant in rilkes
aufzeichnungen des malte laurids präge
ist es ja so dass
sich am anfang schon fragt habe ich
überhaupt noch bekannte wenn ich mich
ständig verändere wem soll ich dann
eigentlich noch einen brief schreiben
wenn ich mich verändert habe dann sind
das doch nicht mehr meine bekannten die
mich das letzte mal vor ein paar monaten
gesehen haben das sind fragen die in den
sozialen medien überhaupt nicht in
dieser weise gestellt werden weil große
erzählungen des lebens aufstiegs
geschichten aufgemacht werden es ist
eher so wie bei alma mahler werfel bei
ihrer autobiografie wo sie am ende
schreibt und nun liegt mein ganzes leben
vor mir als sein roman aber sie hat
vergessen dass sie selbst sich gerade
diesen roman des lebens geschrieben hat
ja das ist diese linearität na also und
das habe ich schon auch festgestellt und
ich glaube das ist das ist dieser das
ist einer der kern momente den ich
glaube ich hatte dass ich mich überhaupt
angefangen habe mit diesem thema zu
befassen weil ich gemerkt habe
also es ist ja nicht so dass ich keine
ahnung was für eine identität im
internet hatte aber immerhin habe ich
mir ein paar jahre lang als
freiberufliche journalistin image
aufgebaut oder zumindest irgendeine
facette von mir die irgendwie xy aussah
ich hab irgendwann das gefühl gehabt ich
sitze auf facebook in einem dorf das so
klein ist jedes mal wenn ich durchlaufe
gucken sie alle hinter den gardinen
hervor und und und und und kontrollieren
was ich tue also ich hatte genau dieses
gefühl dass ich das gefühl hatte ich
kann aus dieser identität ich mir selber
erschaffen habe nicht mehr raus
beziehungsweise ich kann nichts
konträres tun das ist aber vorwiegend
auch in meinem kopf gewesen und das ist
genau diese autos konfektion das ist
genau dieser punkt dass wir im echten
leben viel widersprüchlicher und viel
facettenreicher sind also wir uns
darstellen und das wird glaube ich auch
gesellschaftlich nicht mehr darauf klar
kommen und das gefühl haben weil ich im
internet immer gleich aussehen muss ich
wenn ich ihnen tage aus dem bett steige
auch immer genau gleich aussehen und es
funktioniert nicht ja ich meine ich habe
wieder das gefühl das ist wieder etwas
einseitig ich habe andere beispiel dem
kopf leute spielerisch mehrere
identitäten ausprobieren dinge tun das
ist fast eine kunstform ist auch sich
selbst zu inszenieren das gibt's ja
alles auch hier sie beschreiben jetzt
sozusagen dieses gesetz die hölle das
sind die anderen dieses tor auf die
überwachen sich gegenseitig und so und
man kann sich nicht mehr verändern aber
es ist durchaus nicht nur ein großes
freiheits versprechen sondern für viele
leute ist das eben klar installieren sie
dann auch diese vielfalt aber das lässt
es doch auch zu ich glaube da wo es sich
loest von den reinen kommerziellen
interessen wo nicht der werbe körper
mittelpunkt steht da kann das
tatsächlich passieren und da ist das
eine möglichkeit sich selbst zu
verwirklichen denn das gehört natürlich
dazu dass man gewisse tradition in dem
man sich befindet abgibt dass man sich
emanzipiert das heißt wirklich den
väterlichen hof verlässt und sich selbst
kreiert nur was wir im influencer
marketing ganz stark haben ist jetzt so
ein kult um authentizität so als sei das
was aus meinen augen fließt die tränen
das gefühl das wirklich wahre echte oder
wenn ich mich ungeschminkt zeige dann
ist das die wirklichkeit und das ist
natürlich fatal dieser glaube weil man
glaubt damit
bei einer wirklichkeit tatsächlich
anzukommen es gibt ja in thomas manns
felix krull schon diese frage dass er da
einen künstler sieht der eigentlich
vollkommen ramponiert ist er aber auf
der bühne noch ganz großartig tanzen
kann und also in der garderobe sieht da
sieht er dieses zusammengekauert
männchen und fragt sich was ist denn
eigentlich der glut wurden wann ist er
dann wirklich echt wenn er als
poetischer funken einer sommernacht uns
erscheint oder wenn er auf unserer hand
liegt und sich elendig krümmt und ich
glaube man muss schon sagen ja dieser
poetische funkel ist vielleicht das wo
man am meisten selbst ist
beziehungsweise ich glaube schon man
muss sich eine maske anziehen um ganz
bei sich selbst anzukommen und was die
influenza jetzt tun ist so eine
authentizität maske zu präsentieren aber
in wahrheit ist ihre reine
maskenhaftigkeit eigentlich noch viel
ehrlicher als jetzt wenn sie wirklich
noch anfang authentisch zu sein sehr
interessant also es gibt ja dieses
phänomens habe ich vor vier jahren
kennengelernt diesen nude look also wenn
man sie schminkt und das sieht dann
danach so aus als hätte man sich nicht
geschminkt das fasst das so zusammen das
wake up frisur die sehr lange braucht
das ist diese inszenierte authentizität
die sie angesprochen haben oder unter
anderem
dass ich mich gerade davon haben so viel
ich glaube davon erholen dass sie dass
sie über den youtube gesprochen haben
als männer den wahrscheinlich ja ich
weiß nicht ob sie leben kennen aber ja
also ich aus frau lebe mit dieser
realität
dass ich mich dagegen oder dafür
entscheiden kann aber ich glaube nicht
dass irgendeine frau an diesem youtube
vorbeikommt und jedes mal ist es eine
entscheidung was heißt denn jetzt
authentisch und ist jetzt schminken
authentisch oder nicht aber das führt
jetzt in die diskussion dass wir sowieso
immer alle bewertet werden aber ich
glaube also das ist genau ich wäre nicht
ganz einverstanden mit ihnen dass ich
habe schon das gefühl dass ich leuten
auf instagram folge die das mit dem wein
ganz ehrlich meinen das sind dann aber
traumatherapeuten und ich folge
natürlich anderen leuten aber ich glaube
ja aber die zum teil auch dinge
enttabuisieren es gibt ja auch menschen
die von ihrer depression sprechen von
ihr ihre magersucht offen sprechen und
so was es heißt wichtige tabu fragen
werden dann auch irgendwie ja öffentlich
gemacht habe wo es gebraucht damit genau
und und trotzdem glaube ich also sie
haben gesagt ja und es ist alles frei
ich glaube es stimmt beides und ich
glaube man kann in den sozialen medien
frei sein und trotzdem ich kenne
niemanden auch wenn er noch so
authentisch im internet unterwegs ist
das hat einen preis du wirst zu einer
öffentlichen figur und du hast du hast
eine schedule wenn du postest und du
hast du also das aber das ist eben
wiederum das ist nicht nur social media
wir sind menschliche und soziale wesen
und eine abweichung wird sozial
sanktioniert also ich muss da gar nicht
ins internet ich kann hier in zürich
meine tasche einen sitz oder ich kann
irgendwie ich kann sonst ich kann laut
telefonieren im tram und ich werde mit
blicken bestraft soll das ist nicht die
norm innerhalb der ich mich bewege und
und und das heißt das internet ist nicht
per se böse sondern sondern es ist in
meinen augen schon immer immer enger
geworden was ist überhaupt erlaubt und
was nicht also wir wir reden immer von
inklusion und bot die positive titel
linie der wir uns bewegen dürfen ist
wahnsinnig schnell und es werden ihnen
alle psychiaterin und psychiater ich
habe da mal eine große geschichte zu
gemacht was ist eigentlich los warum
sind die jugendpsychiatrie gefolgt das
ist einer der gründe dass immer
gepredigt wird otto beisheim gruppe ist
sondern das nie und wenn dann bist du
ganz alleine und dann musst du in deinem
individualismus deine eigene marke
kreieren und und so weiter und so fort
und was wir eigentlich brauchen ist
gemeinschaft und dass ein paar leute mal
sagen ganz ruhig muss nichts leisten
kann es eine pyjama party machen du bist
geliebt aber alle gleichzeitig ist dass
die message auf dass die ideologie
genauso
wäre das ja ja und es sind perfekt
ausgeleuchtete leute die sagen sie mal
du selbst und das bedeutet aber sei
eigentlich so wie ich und wenn man sich
nur mal die popkultur und die
gegenkultur der 70er jahre ansieht dann
bemerkt man schon eine größere
diversität da sieht man ganz andere
körperbilder da ist es viel
selbstständiger selbstverständlich ja
dass irgendwelche stars männliche stars
sich auch schminken heute die dann
großen aktivismus daraus dass sie mal
nagellack oder so tragen das ist ja
geradezu lachhaft wenn man sieht wie
weit wir schon mal waren also ich wäre
auch vorsichtig dass wir da wirklich
fortschritte diagnostizieren können im
übrigen glaube ich auch dass viele
tatsächliche gefühle haben werden sie da
sein aber ich glaube nicht dass gefühle
immer authentisch sind ich habe mich
selbst oft dabei ertappt bei großen
gefühlsausbrüchen dass ich da eigentlich
neben mir stand und in den phasen der
selbstbeherrschung noch viel mehr ich
war
also ich habe jetzt noch ein beispiel
dass ich gern noch bringen würde das ist
wirklich für mich so eine große
entdeckten gewesen in der vorbereitung
auf die sendung ich weiß sie haben
mehrere monate nur auf diesen sozialen
medien verbracht aber wir haben ein
bisschen geschaut es gibt ein video das
zeigt wie gefährlich sein kann wie sehr
auch dieses konservative dieser
backlight nicht nur körperlich sondern
auch folgen bilder da bedient werden
haben wir haben dann beispielsweise
gesucht wo eine dame ein land päckli für
ihren mann zubereitet schön ist das
hallo ich habe wieder eine lunchbox für
meinen mann gemacht heute gab es mal
etwas weissbrodt habe ich kleine
häppchen haus belegt ich finde diesen
riffel kater total cool und da so schöne
muster in das grüßen zu schneiden im
letzten video sich viele kommentare
gefunden die gesagt haben ob man sich da
nicht verschämt mein mann schien sich da
nicht führen er ist ein erwachsener mann
und freut sich eine liebevolle pro dose
jeden tag mit auf die arbeit nehmen zu
können die herzen habe ich wieder mit
butter festgeklebt den rutschen sie
nicht
ja ganz schön lange kein guter hat diese
käse herzen schmiert mutter dass sie
hatten ehrlich da kann kein doris day
film mithalten
was löst das bei ihnen nase vermehrt wir
haben überfällig ist ja also ganz
ehrlich ich freue mich ich freue mich
total ich hab da 0 cenis muss und weil
ich grundsätzlich jetzt mal davon
ausgehe weil sie hat das ja thematisiert
auf der metaebene angesagt 0 man waren
freut sich und ich finde
gleichberechtigung oder oder oder
gleichstellung geht eben auch
psychologisch davon aus dass zwei
menschen sich auf augenhöhe begegnen und
wie diese augenhöhe dann schlussendlich
in den alltag integriert wird das ist
nicht mein ding das ist nicht an mir zu
beurteilen das ist jetzt für mich keine
rückständige hausfrau die die sklaven
ihres mannes ist also sie kann ja für
minister in sein und sie hat freude an
sandwiches und er ist froh dass sie das
übernimmt und vielleicht massiert er
ihre füße jeden abend interessanten
leuten sagen wir laufen gefahr sozusagen
nur ihm ein bild zu sehen einer
feministischen person und müssen wieder
lernen auszuhalten dass wir auch viele
sehen in uns drinnen das gibt vielleicht
auch dieses bedürfnis ich glaube um das
noch kurz abzuschließen das ist sehr
integral wichtig also das ist auch im
psycho psychologischen kontext wichtig
also man gewisse psychologische richtung
patchwork also arbeit mit inneren
anteilen und man geht davon aus dass man
ganz viele charaktere in sich drin hat
also ich hab keine ahnung 20 25 und
feministisch manchmal
möchte ich aber auch irgendwie basilikum
züchten dann bin ich die karrieristen
und dann möchte ich irgendwie wieder
eine zehn stunden woche dann will ich
irgendwie dann bin ich die die den
ganzen tag netflix 'nen möchte dann bin
ich die kuh lehrerin dann bin ich die
harmoniesüchtige also wir sind ganz ganz
viele dinge und wir dürfen und das ist
genau das wichtige und es geht finde ich
im aktuellen diskurs auch im digital
dann sehr oft vergessen das ist nicht so
linear also das ist nicht ich bin nicht
also es gibt leute die dann vegan sind
yoga machen und und und und gegen tier
also kann einem wurden das alles ohne
linie ist aber nein wir sind
verschiedene anteile und diese anteile
in uns sind selbst widersprüchlich und
das nur das muss ich lernen auszuhalten
ich bin feministin und um an meinem mann
butter pro der brote und würden sie
sagen die digitalisierung oder die
sozialen medien
lassen das nicht mehr zu diese aktivität
oder diese an biotest ohne hans dass wir
viele sind und möchten uns wie festlegen
ich glaube schon und ich glaube das ist
ja auch das ist dieses mal steckt ding
und das ist dieses aber das sind auch
die das ist auch 20 minuten online oder
das ist auch die bild es ist einfach
eine realität in einem schlagwort in
einem satz in 60 sekunden
und das kann ein anfang sein aber nichts
ich glaube ich glaube es ist kein zufall
dass alles gesagt so populär ist und
dass dann leute auf twitter irgendwie
schreiben ach krass ich dachte das ist
ein arschloch oder ich wollte den gar
nicht anhören und jede person wird dir
nach drei vier stunden auch eine alice
schwarzer egal wer plötzlich sympathisch
weil gemerkt ach so das sind gedanken
dahinter oder das sind das sind gefühle
dahinter und ich verstehe vielleicht die
ansichten nicht aber ich verstehe das
gemeinsame gefühl dahinter
können wir ja schon auch einen gewissen
backlash diagnostizieren zwar haben wir
in florenz können die sich emanzipieren
konnten auch ökonomisch wahrscheinlich
ist diese tick talkerin die wir gerade
gesehen haben die da die brote schmieren
man ökonomisch erfolgreicher sogar als
ihr mann der arbeiten geht nur das bild
das verkörpert wird und ich finde es
auch unproblematisch wenn eine frau auch
mal butterbrot ihren mann steht aber das
bild das eigentlich immer mehr
gezeichnet wird im influenza turm ist
die frau ist als frau auf die häusliche
rolle
konzentriert sie kann in dieser
häusliche sphäre sich austoben darf
innerhalb dieser häusliche sphäre auch
karriere machen denn da findet all das
influenza marketing statt in der regel
in den eigenen vier wänden aber
produziert werden nach außen bilder wie
aus einem doris day film der 50er 60er
jahre für eine follower schafft die dann
nicht sich emanzipiert sondern die
eigentlich dann diese produkte kaufen
muss um auch die perfekte hausfrau zu
sein und das ist das große problem dass
diese emanzipation die das stattfindet
quasi auf den schultern der follower
rennen stattfindet die sich nicht
emanzipieren können denn werden sie sich
emanzipieren wären sie nicht mehr
follower und würden die produkte kaufen
und dann wäre aber meine frage wie viele
von denen hatten emanzipierte mutter zu
hause also das ist nicht also ja absolut
man hat diesen einfluss und ja es ist
alles innerhalb von zwei sekunden
also
antastbar oder oder konsumierbar und ja
ich finde auch und unterschreibe ich
dann auch immer ein buch dieses thema
also ich ein ganzes kapitel zu eltern
und kindern und die wäsche radio zu
sorgen das buch heißt verbundenheit
erscheint im januar
genau im ullstein verlag in der januar
und
und und es ist integral wichtig
natürlich eine grenze zu ziehen und zu
sagen wo ist der einflussbereich meines
kindes wer hat einfluss auf dieses kind
auf diese entwicklung auf die weltsicht
also vor allem in den ersten jahren und
und da irgendwie auch dieses kind und
auch die ganze familie vor vor vor
diesen ganzen vor dieser ganzen
überschwemmung
annan an ideologien auch und dann an
konsum erwartungen auch und an diese
ganze idee von eben das in 12 jährige
kinder oder mädchen hat nackte tik tok
videos drehen ja dann müsste man halt
mal drüber reden was machst du hier und
warum ist das nicht gut und nur weil sie
können das ja gar nicht einordnen das
ist eben wieder verdient die wollen ja
mit anderen mitziehen und wenn die dann
sagen ich finde das schön das machen
andere auch ich finde das cool ich guck
das gerne so gut aber es macht spaß ich
glaube man muss auch da hin und wieder
mal den riegel vorschieben wie man das
früher ja auch getan hat in der
erziehung da gab's noch zeit wenn man
nach hause gehen muss und dann muss es
auch grenzen geben was man zeigt wenn
man zwölf dreizehn jahre alt ist und
dass da so eine hyper sexualisierung
stattfindet ist ja nicht von der hand zu
weisen deshalb sollte man da sehr
aufpassen wenngleich es natürlich
unglaublich schwierig ist denn so ein
smartphone ermöglicht natürlich auch
dass man sehr viel im geheimen tun kann
aber ich denke dass das ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem ist
dass man jetzt auch nicht nur auf die
algorithmen schieben kann aber wichtig
ist festzuhalten wir müssen auch
vorsichtig sein bei diesen
enttabuisierung die da jetzt so gerade
nach vorne gebracht werden inwieweit ist
sich da wirklich um enttabuisierung
handelt oder wie viel offene türen
werden da eingerannt oder bei manchen
dingen fragt man sich auch muss das
überhaupt enttabuisiert fernseher ein
spiel machen muss jeder muss jede
geschlechtskrankheit in langen videos
von influenza jetzt noch mit einer
werbekooperation besprochen versehen
werden mein co autor und niemand sagt
gerne wir müssen mal anfangen tabus zu
enttabuisieren und ich glaube auch da
sollte man eher mal wieder versuchen ob
man nicht doch noch mal an so eine
schöne alte bürgerliche unterscheidung
zwischen öffentlich und privat
zurückdenkt die ist ja längst verloren
ja leider aber wenn wir jetzt wir sind
schon am ende der sendung haben keine
zeit aber trotzdem noch mal kurz also
was tun die alte lady in frage
gesellschaftlich was würden sie sagen
sind die wichtigsten stellschrauben
drehen sollten in den nächsten fünf
jahre politisch müssen die plattform
mehr reguliert werden und es braucht
mehr transparenz über die algorithmische
gewalt aber gesamtgesellschaftlich
müssen gegenwelten aufgetan werden und
zwar auch im netz also draußen natürlich
die unmittelbare begegnung aber auch im
netz denn es liegt er nur einen klick
entfernt das idiotische video von babys
beauty palace wir kaufen alles was mit
den buchstaben b anfängt bei amazon oder
sternstunden der philosophie und
letzteres das wäre ja schön wenn da
jemand drauf also diese gegen werden
einerseits aufbauen im digitalen und
danach sich zu fragen was ist eigentlich
das motiv also das problem mit der
enttabuisierung warum mache ich das
jetzt und das andere ist diese große
vielleicht politische frage wie wir mit
transparenz umgehen ob ihr diese großen
konzerne diese monopole sie plädiere
nicht für eine zerschlagung ist hier
richtig verstehe sondern für mehr
transparenz verfeuern eine zerschlagung
würde nichts bringen also man kann nicht
zehn instagram herstellen man könnte
vielleicht whats app von facebook von
instagram lösen und hätte den konzern ob
das viel bringen würde ich bin da
skeptisch tik tok steht für sich allein
und es trotzdem enorm wirkmächtig und
was würden sie sagen individuellen
psychologisch
was heißt eine humanere umgang mit
diesen patienten und diesen plattformen
also ein humaner umgang also ich also
geht natürlich vieles das man tun kann
aber wenn ich mich auf etwas begrenzen
würde dann ist es und das klingt so blöd
bringen physische distanz also bring
raum zwischen dich und dem digitalen
täglich also sei das dass du dein
smartphone nicht mehr ins bett also
nicht mehr und zwar nie aber bringt
nicht mehr ins schlafzimmer und und und
und faden pc herunter und legt in den
anderen raum und geben eine halbe stunde
spazieren ohne und es ist eine physische
entkopplung die aber überhaupt uns
wieder auch nur ansatzweise in so ein
gefühl einbringen kann von h okay die
welt geht nicht unter ach so fünf
stunden später ist instagram immer noch
da und nicht immer ich sage immer nicht
immer nach jeder socke die wäsche
waschen nicht immer nach jeder mail
nicht immer alles instantly nicht immer
24 stunden sieben konstant wie immer
immer immer gerade sofort alles
abarbeiten sondern das ganze das
digitale bündeln und und und richtig
wirklich sich mal die entscheidende
frage stellen wenn man feststellt
irgendwas ist zuviel digital was sagt
mir das was ist es was ich wirklich als
sehne es mehr gemeinschaft ist es
mitspracherecht ist es gesehen werden
und sich dann wirklich die unangenehme
frage stellen werde ich von meinem mann
oder von meiner ehefrau gesehen ist es
mir eigentlich zu viel mit den kindern
werde ich überhaupt mache ich die arbeit
die ich machen möchte und es muss auch
nicht alles festgehalten werden man kann
auch einfach mal etwas erleben es hat
sie eigentlich sind maximilian schell
marlene dietrich nochmal filmen wollte
sagte sie ich bin zu tode fotografiert
wurden das sollten wir uns mal wieder in
erinnerung sie liefen wir das stichwort
ich möchte ihnen etwas vorschlagen sie
werden mich dafür hassen würde gerne
jetzt 111 machen mit ihnen in der
sendung okay machen wir das damit wieder
sendung nach posten können so besser
laufen wir jetzt beginnen wir genau die
muster wie macht sie außerdem in der
presse und in dem dehoga
ironisch ist schwierig da wird man sehr
schnell zum
mittäter aber wir machen uns für die
gute sache denn wir wollen ja nur darauf
verweisen auf dieses tolle gespräch das
dann sich an ansehen und hoffen dass die
leute nicht nur das vorteilen scheint
nicht nur ja das soll jetzt der kreis
und lech posen
[Musik]
dank für diese für diesen ritt durch die
sozialen medien die ich sehr viel
aussagen über unsere tiefsten seen sich
die aber auch über unsere gesellschaft
vielen dank herr schmidt und frank
ja danke ihnen fürs mit denken wenn sie
jetzt mehr über das phänomen influenza
erfahren möchten wir verlosen zwei
bücher von wolfgang schmidt schreiben
sie mir auf instagram oder auf unserer
website unter der rubrik mehr zur
sendung nächste woche ist der
wissenschafts direktor der nasa zu gast
bei uns wolfram eilenberger spree mit
thomas zu buchen über die zukunft der
raumfahrt und über die stellung des
menschen im kosmos jetzt gleichzeitig
die sternstunde musik den ersten teil
einer dreiteiligen serie zum legendären
jazz festival in montreux das seit über
50 jahren musik größen aus der ganzen
welt an den genfer see lockt von rita
franklin über ray charles bis david
bowie
bleiben sie also dran und bis bald
[Musik]